factorizar r cuadrada + 4 r menos 45 y
aunque yo sé que esto es fácil de
factorizar por otros métodos
quiero seguir factor izando por
agrupación y recuerda que para
factorizar por agrupación lo primero que
hay que fijarnos es en dos números tales
que multiplicados me den el coeficiente
que está al lado de la erre cuadrada y
el coeficiente libre es decir a por d me
tiene que dar 1 x menos 45 1 x menos 45
es menos 45 y por otra parte la suma de
estos mismos números a + b me tienen que
dar el coeficiente que está al lado del
aire a más b tiene que ser igual a 4 muy
bien y ahora voy a buscar dos números
que mucho multiplicación me dé menos 45
y que su suma de 4 que es números puedo
pensar en ellos y bueno lo que quiero
que veas que no quiero tomar números muy
grandes o muy alejados entre sí porque
45 por ejemplo se puede actualizar en 45
y 1 pero 45 y 1 están muy lejos su
diferencia nunca me va a dar 4 entonces
me voy a tomar dos números más cercanos
entre sí tal vez
3 y 15 no me sirve más 9 y 5 9 y 5 creo
que son los números bastante cercanos
los cual nos pueden dar el valor de 4 si
nosotros nos sumamos los restamos así
que voy a tomarme el 5 positivo y
después el 9 negativo y si te das cuenta
5 x menos 9 me da menos 45 y si me tomo
la suma me va a quedar 5 menos 9 lo cual
me da menos 4 que no es 4 pero si yo de
cambió el signo a estos dos números es
decir en menos 5 y 9 esto sí me va a dar
44 positivo y perfecto entonces ya tengo
mis dos números tales que multiplicados
me dan menos 45 y sumados me dan 4 por
lo tanto ahora voy a romper esta
expresión y la voy a poner de la
siguiente manera en lugar de poner 4 r
vamos a poner menos 5 ri9 r así que
déjame ponerlo aquí esto lo voy a
escribir como 9 r menos 5 r este de aquí
es lo que voy a romper de este trinomio
para que yo lo puedas actualizar por
agrupación mientras que por otra parte
tenemos re cuadrada menos 45 al final y
bueno como factor hicimos por agrupación
nos fija
en los primeros dos términos y de aquí
vamos a factorizar lo más que podamos es
decir de estos primeros dos términos me
va a quedar r que multiplica a r9 es lo
más que se puede actualizar el reporte
me queda r cuadrada y reponer me quedan
9 r y después de estos otros dos
términos voy a factorizar lo más que se
pueda que es un -5 menos 5 que
multiplica a r en primer lugar menos 5 r
entre menos 5 me va a dar r y después
tengo menos 45 entre menos 5 lo cual me
da 9 positivo más 9 y entonces ya tengo
esta expresión que tengo aquí y me doy
cuenta que era más 9 es muy factor común
por lo tanto como es factor común lo voy
a factorizar de nuevo y me va a quedar
algo de la siguiente manera r más 9 que
multiplica a su vez a r menos cinco era
más 9 multiplica tanto a efe este arte
cuenta en esta parte de aquí y por otra
parte multiplica menos 5 que es esta
otra parte que tengo aquí por lo tanto
este resultado no va a quedar
r más 9 por r menos 5